partes del submarino indonesio que
desapareció hace cuatro días fueron
halladas a 838 metros de profundidad la
marina indicó que un sumergible de
singapur localizó restos del caeré y
nanga la 402 no fue un error humano
porque siguieron todos los protocolos
durante la sumersión desde el reporte
inicial escuchamos que los preparativos
se llevaron a cabo de forma adecuada y
cuando se sumergió las luces estaban
encendidas así que no hubo ningún apagón
las autoridades señalaron que las partes
trasera y delantera del submarino se
desprendieron de la central
los trajes de escape de emergencia se
guardan dentro de una caja y se usan
sólo en situaciones especiales
encontramos estos sueltos así que debió
presentarse una emergencia pero por
alguna razón la tripulación no pudo
ponérselos este traje fue recuperado con
ayuda del submarino de singapur
los expertos sospechan que la nave
empezó a agrietarse cuando se encontraba
entre 400 y 500 metros bajo la
superficie pues fue diseñada para
hundirse máximo a esa profundidad el
presidente yo como ídolo envío sus
condolencias a los familiares de las
víctimas que estás todos nosotros el
pueblo de indonesia expresamos nuestro
profundo pesar por esta tragedia
especialmente para las familias de la
tripulación son los mejores hijos de
esta nación patriotas que custodian la
soberanía del país pipe ansa
además de singapur australia india y
eeuu participaron en la búsqueda el
sumergible desapareció de los radares
cuando los tripulantes realizaban
ejercicios con torpedos en la madrugada
del miércoles 21 de abril